mais pourquoi l'armée ukrainienne
sont-elles près de tchernobyl début
février les troupes de la garde
nationale ukrainienne ont organisé des
exercices à balles réelles dans des
immeubles abandonnés de pripiat la
grande ville située juste à côté de la
centrale en fait l'objectif c'est de se
préparer à une éventuelle invasion russe
qui on rappelle à plus de cent mille
hommes massés à la frontière mais plutôt
que de s'entraîner dans une base
militaire classique l'armée ukrainienne
a cette fois choisi pripyat car en fait
il s'agit d'une véritable grandes villes
mais sans aucun civil cela leur permet
d'extraire balles réelles de déclencher
des incendies dans des bâtiments des
conditions qui sont proches de la
réalité l'armée précise d'ailleurs les
soldats ukrainien ne se sont pas
entraînés un combat classique mais
plutôt à déloger des personnes armées
dans des bâtiments comme des snipers
pour rappel les 50000 habitants de
pripyat avaient été évacuées en trois
heures le 27 avril 1986 suite au pire
accident nucléaire de l'histoire
survenue à la centrale de tchernobyl